the contouring universe is poised to
overtake the matrix is the most
profitable r-rated series of all time
how did the cinematic exploits of
real-life paranormal investigators ed
and Lorraine Warren get so successful
let's get caught up before the return of
fan favorite haunted doll Annabelle
after her first appearance in the
conjuring the Annabelle doll became a
staple of the conjuring universe and
even got to spin off films of her own
starting with Annabelle in 2014
continuing with the prequel film
Annabelle creation in 2017 the spin-off
series has been a modest financial
success though the first Annabelle
received a relatively cold reception
from critics and audiences the film
still grossed over two hundred and fifty
seven million dollars worldwide
Annabelle creation performed much better
than its predecessor grossing more than
306 million dollars worldwide
it was also better received by critics
and audiences which paved the way for
yet another Annabelle sequel the
upcoming Annabelle comes home while the
previous Annabelle films have featured
scenarios separate from the rest of the
conjuring universe Annabelle comes home
takes us back to the Warren household
Mary demonologists ed and Lorraine
Warren keep a collection of artifacts
recovered from their supernatural cases
in a locked room inside of their home
this safe room is home to numerous
haunted items including the Annabelle
doll and the conjuring films the
Warren's daughter Judy is explicitly
told to stay out of the safe room you
can't go into this room no matter what
remember yes Ted
however in Annabelle comes home Judy's
babysitter Daniella shows a dangerous
curiosity towards the Warrens
artifact room having recently lost her
father Daniella is obsessed with the
afterlife and as a result she
accidentally unleashes the evil spirits
kept within the Warren's home after the
spirits are Unleashed Judy becomes the
primary target for the evil entities
Edward and Lorraine Warren played by
Patrick Wilson and be reformed EAGA are
based on two real-life paranormal
investigators the Warren's are famous
for a multitude of paranormal cases
including the Amityville haunting which
spawned its own franchise horror films
the conjuring is inspired by another
of the Warrens cases that took place at
a Rhode Island farmhouse in the 70s the
Warrens also founded the warren occult
Museum in Connecticut which is home to a
variety of spooky and supposedly haunted
artifacts including the real Annabelle
doll though the Warrens are well-known
the two are considered controversial
among skeptics neurologist Steven
novella president of the New England
skeptical Society told us a day the
Warrens are good at telling ghost
stories you could do a lot of movies
based on the stories they have spun but
there's absolutely no reason to believe
that there is any legitimacy to them
whether or not their work is legitimate
the cultural impact of Edie and Lorraine
Warren particularly on horror films is
undeniable Edie passed away in 2006
while Lorraine passed away on April 18th
2019 in the conjuring films the Warrens
artifact room is shown to have numerous
haunted objects from the couple's
previous cases throughout the series the
Warren's have advised people in their
house not to enter the room or touch the
objects since the possibility of freeing
any of the spirits contained within
could be dangerous though we've only
seen glimpses of all the artifacts
housed in the Warren house Annabelle
comes home places a bigger importance on
the spirits in that room producer Peter
Safran told den of geek the idea of
actually setting a film around the
artifact room was something that we had
in our mind for a while we just thought
that the third Annabelle movie is the
opportunity to really raise the stakes
Gary Doberman the director of Annabelle
comes home is no stranger to conjuring
universe previously da Berman has served
as a writer for multiple films in the
franchise including Annabelle Annabelle
creation and the nun Doberman even got
to go on location with the crew as they
shot the nun in Romania a level of
involvement not always guaranteed for a
screenwriter in an interview with
Collider franchise producer Peter Safran
gave a blunt explanation as to why da
Berman made the transition from writer
to director for Annabelle comes home he
got to a place as a writer where he
wanted people to stuff up his movies
outside of his work on the conjuring
franchise Donovan also worked on the
2017 adapt a
it and is slated as a writer for the
upcoming horror projects are you afraid
of the dark and it's chapter 2 in the
Annabelle comes home trailer a new
supernatural entity can be seen standing
in a corner of the Warrens artifact room
after Daniella goes against the advice
of Judy it enters the room were all of
the possessed objects of kept she hears
the ghostly voice of a woman that
[Music]
wedding dress belongs to the entity
known as the bride early reports say
that the bride is a new monster in the
series that possesses women who wear her
dress and convinces them to kill their
husbands after each woman is made to
take out her new spouse the bride goes
ahead and kills her to the introduction
of a new demonic presence could be a
sign of films to come especially since
previous spin-off films have been
introduced in a similar way in both of
the main conjuring films Lorraine Warren
has the ability to see and communicate
with ghosts and demons in the first film
this ability is demonstrated when she's
able to see the evil spirit that's
haunting the Peron family
the conjuring - meanwhile begins with
Lorraine having a dark vision during a
seance and communicating with the demon
terrorizing a family Lorraine is also
able to see the evil nun entity
throughout the film in the trailer for
Annabelle comes home Judi mentions that
she can see things just like her mother
Lorraine this implies a prominent plot
point in Annabelle comes home will
revolve around Judy's apparent ability
to communicate with the evil spirits
a trend in the conjuring universe is
that the sets for many of the films are
allegedly cursed the unit publicist for
Annabelle comes home told PopSugar that
ever since the conjuring - all of the
sets have been blessed by Catholic
priests prior to filming on the
conjuring - we had an exorcist that was
recommended to us by Lorraine Warren a
friend of hers who sanctioned by the
church to exorcise buildings but not
people apparently there are different
levels of sanctions for exorcisms
with all the films in the conjuring
universe it can get a bit confusing
trying to remember how each story fits
into the series timeline Annabel comes
home sits at an interesting intersection
in the timelines of both the Annabel
spin-off series in the main conjuring
films Annabel creation starts off in the
year 1943 though the bulk of the film
takes place in 1955 with a group of
young girls trying to survive their
encounter with the demon inside the
Annabelle doll the original Annabel
takes place in 1967 as a young couple
tried to protect their Souls from the
evil intent of the doll with the help of
father Perez Annabel comes home will
take place in 1971 but it's not the only
film that takes place during that year
the new film shares its setting with the
original conjuring film and the opening
of the conjuring the Warren's take the
possessed doll into their custody just
before they leave for Connecticut with
the addition of Annabel comes home the
conjuring Universe has come full circle
on the screen ed Warren is a devoted
demonologist who works in tandem with
his wife however Patrick Wilson the
actor who plays the late ed Warren
started out far from the tense
atmospheres and spooky settings of
horror films Wilson started his
entertainment career by playing leading
men in different Broadway musicals and
not only did the act sing and dance on
stage he excelled in 2001 Wilson was
nominated for the Tony Award for the
Best Actor in a musical finding himself
listed alongside acting heavyweights
such as Kevin Chamberlain Matthew
Broderick and Nathan Lane the following
year Wilson was the only member of the
previous year's nomination list to
return though he ultimately lost to John
Lithgow aside from starring in musicals
and playing a demonologist on screen
Wilson has a rather diverse film
portfolio he appeared in the 2009 Zack
Snyder film Watchmen where he plays
night owl
a former superhero reluctantly convinced
to put his costume back on after a spree
of mysterious deaths after getting to
play a hero in Watchmen Wilson returned
to the world of comic book adaptations
to play King worm in the 2018
blockbuster Aquaman Vera Farmiga has had
a successful career on the stage in film
and behind the camera but the story of
how she got here is certainly unique to
say the least
Fermi grew up in a small Ukranian
immunity and Passaic New Jersey she
discovered her love of performance after
auditioning for a high school stage
production and landing the principal
role from there she became part of a
semi-professional Ukrainian dance group
after high school ver MIGA went to
Syracuse University to study acting
ultimately embarking on a professional
stage point where she was noticed by
television and film producers this
attention has led to roles in the
departed down to the bone and the
Manchurian Candidate after appearing on
screen alongside the likes of Meryl
Streep Heath Ledger and Roberts Niro she
was nominated for an Oscar in 2010 for
her supporting role and up in the air
Annabelle is a terrifying antagonist on
screen and the ostensibly true story
behind the real-life Annabelle doll is
just as horrifying supposedly the
Annabelle doll was bought by a woman for
her daughter Donna unfortunately after
Donna was given the doll she and her
roommates started to notice some strange
occurrences around the house a medium
claimed that the doll hosted the spirit
of a young girl named Annabelle Higgins
who was found dead where their apartment
was built according to the medium
Annabelle wanted to remain close to the
girls feeling compassionate the
roommates gave Annabelle's spirit
permission to stay with them in their
apartment however after recurring bad
dreams and suspicious noises in the
apartment the Warrens stepped in we are
beyond terrified we don't know what's
going on or what to do can you help us
yes we can they told the girls that the
Annabelle doll was inhabited by a
demonic entity and the doll was
exercised and given to the warrens for
safekeeping
after Annabelle allegedly attempted to
have a priest killed the Warrens moved
it to their occult Museum there it
remains a popular attraction for
tourists and supernatural enthusiasts
well pretty much every film in the
conjuring universe has deep themes
relating to christianity the Annabelle
films take a bit of a different tack
they usually feature concepts regarding
the nature of motherhood and the
sacrifices the parents have to make the
protective families in Annabelle Mia's
willingness to sacrifice herself shows
how the best mothers are willing to give
everything to keep evil from corrupting
their children Annabelle creation shows
just how desperate grief can
make people in their desperation to get
their daughter back the Mullen family
welcomes what appears to be the spirit
of their dead daughter into their house
however the spirit is actually a demon
that goes on to terrorize the Mullins
and the orphans they taken in as a form
of personal penance with Annabelle comes
home audiences may see some of these
previously explored themes revisited in
the conjuring Lorraine is extremely
concerned with the well-being of her
daughter Judy even seeing visions of her
dead body floating in a river with Judy
now targeted by Annabelle it will be up
to Lorraine to protect her daughter from
the dolls evil influence check out one
of her newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the
conjuring universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]